un hombre resonó este viernes en
argentina cristina fernández los
periódicos del país presentaban en sus
portadas a la noticia que recorría el
mundo y que generó una jornada de masivo
apoyo a la vicepresidenta víctima de un
fallido intento de asesinato la plaza de
mayo- se colmó por completo banderas con
mensajes de aliento imágenes de eva
perón y música marcaron la jornada
ayer nos salió una bala por una cuestión
técnica
evidentemente porque estaba todo probado
de que la bala tenía la intención de
salir y esa bala es el resumen de un
discurso de odio el presidente alberto
fernández declaró feriado el viernes una
luz verde para todo el que quiso mostrar
su respaldo a la líder peronista la
posibilidad de que a cristina le pueda
pasar algo
realmente es impensada para nosotros
realmente nos salvamos
de algo terrible que no puedo ni
siquiera comprender qué hubiera pasado
si a christina le hubiera pasado algo
anoche
tendría que ser más cuidado de la
presidenta vicepresidente haciendo
nuestra visión tendría que tener más
custodia más cuidado está bien que ella
se debe al público como el dicho pero
tengo una muestra más de apoyo a alberto
fernández visitó a la vicepresidenta que
más tarde a pesar del peligro que se
cierne sobre ella se volvió a acercar a
la multitud que la respalda en el barrio
recoleta hace más de diez días incluso
sus opositores más férreos como el ex
presidente de mauricio macri condenaron
la agresión contra cristina fernández